Hello, I've been doing a lot of research
into what might have gone wrong
along with the thoughts
from the developer.
>> Glad to hear it,
what could we have done differently?
>> It's a bit hard to describe without
a picture here, let me show you.
>> Firebase has the ability to
nest data up to 32 levels deep.
But don't let that tempt you,
generally speaking nesting data is
a bad idea in a NoSQL database.
When you create a data structure with
deep nesting, it hurts performance and
can result in a disastrous design.
This is because in Firebase
when you read a data node,
you also retrieve all of
the children of that node.
And remember, Firebase is designed
to be a real time solution for
mobile applications.
Taking something like 20 seconds or
longer to read in data
doesn't qualify as real time.
So what's the solution
to this challenge?
The solution is to
denormalize your data,
which is basically the process of
ignoring how objects might normally be
nested, such as having all items
contained within a shopping list.
And instead focusing on
adding some extra data and
or regrouping data to make getting the
exact data you need for your app simple.
This results in queries that have the
needed information to return results but
not at the expense of performance.
So let's look at a before and
after example in Firebase.
In shopping lists ++heyday,
there was an internal chat application.
That's all gone now, but
we can still look at the schema.
First, let's look at
the anti-pattern for this chat app.
The chat app had rooms,
users, and messages.
Let's say the main screen of the app was
a list of rooms that the user can enter
to chat in.
For this, we need to grab a list of
chatroom names from the database,
which would involve us
getting the data from here.
In the first example, we see that
in order to list the names of rooms
requires the entire room's tree
to be downloaded to the client.
We have all this extra
data we don't want.
Imagine how much data would have to be
queried if you had a thousand rooms
worth of data.
Let's look at a denormalized example.
Here data is split into separate paths,
which in turn allow for the information
to be downloaded in segments related
to what the app actually needs.
The list of users is
downloaded as needed.
Messages are fetched separately.
And this allows the application
to remain performant.